welcome to this video playing and a note
from the US and he's the king of pre
moves obviously the games are won right
on the first moves if you play the move
so quickly that you yeah basically it's
just fantastic alright so let's see and
what happens if we actually play a game
yeah he's starting with 90 67 which is
very uncommon against white set up and
for good reason the night simply does
not belong on c7 okay Bishop f4 and
Queen d2 as a possible way to set up the
pieces okay yeah just one one way to go
okay let's see I'm I'm always interested
in exchanging bishops here this is even
more interesting in this concrete
position because I haven't played f3 not
weakening my dark squares so much I
think cannot clear into probably
covering be two and then go for Bishop
h6 i don't i don't need to play Bishop
86 but its own it feels like it's
helpful yeah that's interesting might be
five I guess I'll exchange this Bishop
it doesn't do much good at the moment
and now trade this off
I need this protection of a form night
to be five wouldn't have helped in that
aspect ok so I wanted to exchange here
anyway the question is some what is he
doing 95 to c4 is that the idea maybe
age 3 95 f 494 Queenie to something like
that yeah this might be if this might be
a playable for black he also has the
idea to play Queen age form f 39 h 2
rather embarrassing okay but this seems
useful the question is what am i doing
right here to to address this night see
for EDM
yeah i can just attack be five it's one
idea
yeah well he's just playing relatively
random moves hoping for the best picture
page 3 it's probably the idea I came
takes Queen takes and the night gfor the
idea i mean i can just take b5 here so
one one way to go takes Queen takes is
this really dangerous Queen G&I g4 is
dangerous I can still probably take my
don't um yeah I should take I mean queen
PS on a three and Knight g4 and I just
move the rook there is no one no made
really not
yeah still not clear if I should should
have allowed that yeah I mean Bishop g4
maybe instead of Bishop h3 this could be
it could be a tricky move
yeah now we now is investing not a large
amount of time where you actually have
to sacrifice well what else is there
otherwise I'll just take take the six
and and win it win the game he's already
on the point of no return yeah maybe
Bishop g4 this might be might be
interesting yeah but I think Bishop e3 I
need to do that may be why is he
hesitating here actually Bishop e3 is
there a big big reply to that mm-hm
night and 96 maybe 96 could be a good
reply intending the possible night f5
may just protecting now remarkable
okay I'll just I just put it back
winning the spawn isn't too too bad the
question is still can you take or not is
not yeah a hard time to understand any
of that okay I really think it's almost
forced to to do something drastic but he
doesn't okay um yeah okay seven and he
might play would be aid grab became
thats an active way to play don't run
one lies Marina that's that's not great
it should be five yeah okay Bishop f1f
93 intending night at five but this is
me young Chui that's not really helping
in any way
not clear then let's just wait what's
what's happening here night f5 which is
a very simple trick
yeah well my rationale is that I can
take f1 next move it's not clear way is
going there are some attacking ideas
here anyway with 95 queen age 6 for
instance if the Queen goes all the way
back to the eighth I might have this
move ready you know I should still give
this check of course check winning the
Queen again check I'm one of seven
check Queen Queen to g5 or something
check check check check threatening
Queen g6 that's the major bread
checkmate in the mate yea sorry I'm
always a bit pissed off if they play
those instant moves and I don't
understand why why why would you just
use 12 seconds to to put put up yeah I
don't know okay um here white white is
just a bit better it's it's typical
benoni structure but damn it did so it
since it's difficult it's difficult to
play and yeah I don't know Jana that's
not too bad for black I mean I mean he
hit off of this stuff instantly but it's
not so terrible i didn't i didn't really
refute it I didn't really do that the
computer wants to take with the night
here and play Queen situ or f3 ever
that's also not brilliant yeah if i
don't know maybe maybe around here there
is something better putting the night on
c7 and playing for b5 is really not
great in the structure but this this the
app this wasn't too bad it didn't turn
out too bad i'm making some mistakes
here i'm pretty sure maybe maybe i need
to address this night be five idea
better
now the computer is coming up with F 395
night a tool which is very computer ish
yeah the the idea is that the rook is
trapped em you can go here but this is
the trap please yeah the black can play
even this this weird move which is
completely strange Queen takes the
should be tool they would be to add
equal according to the engine yeah I
don't don't get any of it okay this is
what we play it and and here i was
really surprised that you didn't take on
age three and play looked yet which is
funny enough the computer move I really
thought you needed to do something
drastic but it turns out that I don't
really have a problem here very true I
mean it's very tricky like that clear up
the eight but the computer is not giving
me a huge idea you probably have some
enough activity ITIF four wins for
whites okay yeah I didn't consider that
I just blunder two should be 5i this is
this seems this is good for black accord
good for wide according to the computer
I'm quicker here on f7 with e6 and and
stuff like that okay and this is just
just losing yeah you just you can just
drop the King back janya here it's it's
it's still good for black but it seems
to be tricky but he instantly took the
eye instead of just retreating which
isn't clear at all I mean
I can I can take take the rook this
night dear three yeah the storm is good
for black yeah buddy instantly took the
night and gave away the Queen check
check yeah okay here's nothing to
analyze yeah pretty pretty bad game by
me I mean 91's were really bad really
bad yeah I'm always a bit bit confused
or not I don't know if they play all
those moves in subway I don't understand
it and it makes me make strange things
wrong alright thanks for watching